hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess tournament
uh with a game uh between you've seen
nothing uh with a game between yanni
permission magnus carlsen we've already
seen a game
from round one where magnus was able to
win with the black pieces against that
sneak sneakily prepared line so here we
have a repetition of the line but
uh instead of declining that juicy pawn
magnus actually goes for it and
with that move uh so just let's just go
over to that position so
i like in game one and nipple opens with
e4 and the game two of course ended with
a draw the one where magnus had the
white pieces
so here c5 with knight to f3 d6
and d4 so everything the same as in game
one captures captures knight f6 knight
c3
and the magnus again goes for the knight
of sicilian and the rook to g1 preparing
g for g5
and magnus does everything the same
alike in game one we have b5
g4 and bishop to b7 with a double attack
on the pawn
and nepo again extends the invitation
have added the the e4 pawn is all yours
and here magnus actually captures that
in game one he went for knight to d7
he didn't want to go into any
unnecessary complications as this is a
rapid game
and basically with this capture magnus
says the nipple
uh i don't care how much you prepared
this line with the little time i had in
between games
i prepared sufficiently to refute your
idea
so okay nipple captures we have knight
captures bishop captures and now
not queen to e2 the move we discussed in
the previous video
or queen to g4 is a known tigran
petrossian uh played it uh once again
smirnov uh but here nepo goes for a4 and
it is already as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game
and now you might you might do b4 you
might capture you might do a lot of
things
magnus goes for e5 instead he first
wants to dislodge the knight from the
active d5 square
however the problem is that nepo goes a
captures on b5 he gives up the knight
for a very
very wild position for example e
captures on the four
queen captures attacks the bishop now
you either move the bishop or you go
queen e7 threaten some nasty discoveries
bishop to e3 blocking and now a captures
on b5 as the bishop is now defending the
rook so the point is
white will capture with the bishop and
here we have a very complicated position
yeah if you go king to d8
then your king is on d8 and of course if
you play knight to d7 then the game is
just lost white will capture on d7
and you can't keep an eye on both of
these uh these guys so here
of course once you move if queen
captures then just queen captures
followed by captures
and of course if king captures it's not
much different you can just capture the
rook on a8
and after the bishop captures just go
queen to a7
check king will have to move and now
just capture here and you are of course
much better here not just up upon but
your position is also much better
uh so here uh instead after this a
captures on b5 move
we have bishop to e7 by magnus not of
course touching the knight
and rook to g for now nepo going all out
with with
the engine moves the bishop is under
attack but now a captures on b5 by
magnus
saying okay now we can trade uh your
rook is under attack and if we capture
it then i also save my bishop
so here bishop captures on b5 with check
by nepo
knight the d7 magnus now blocks and the
bishop to d2 just
the defense defends the rook here and
again
uh wha what do you play here well just
bishop to b7 by magnus now gets the
bishop out of harm's way
and knight to f5 by nipple putting some
pressure on these squares here also g7
is under attack and magnus says
i don't care about about your knight
here g6 is an option now however magnus
just decides to castle king side and he
says
i'm going to enjoy my position now as
i've castled the safety
uh however rooked captures an a8 by
nipple bishop captures and now
rook to h4 and here already nepo has
some very nasty ideas queen h5 followed
by queen to h7 checkmate
magnus prevents it he goes g6 and now uh
not moving the knight but rather queen
to g4 nepo just going all out in this
game
uh point is after the knight is captured
just queen h5 you no longer have uh
the h5 square covered and the checkmate
is coming there's nothing to to play
here
so instead after queen g4 we have knight
to c5 by magnus uh and
now comes a very interesting idea
well there are a lot of interesting
ideas here uh for example you have to
check if root captures on h7 is an
option it doesn't lead to checkmate king
captures queen h4 checking here
and now how do you continue there is no
mate this is too slow
however uh well uh yeah if you just go
queen h6 the the pawn captures and
then it just uh runs it runs into a draw
however you could go for
for first check then here and then this
uh but it's pretty much the same thing
captures check like in that one this now
is just forced king j8 and g6
threatening checkmate
but after captures captures you don't
have enough uh
enough material to look for anything
more here you would have to sell for a
perpetual
with queen h6 queen g6 check and so on
so it is an interesting idea although it
does not work
uh so instead of this you could also try
some other things like knight h6 check
right away king g7 knight f5 check
but here magnus will just ignore you and
say okay
i accept the draw you've just wasted
your white pieces
the engines however give in this
position king to f1 is the only winning
move and i mean
i mean what uh how how does that work
probably the thing is that at some point
black will capture this pawn on g5 and
then uh white doesn't want bishop
captures on d2 to come with
check that's probably why king to f1 is
the only attempt
at winning this game so here nepo
instead went for queen to h3 it seems
like it offers the same thing uh just
a real captures on h7 but now uh
magnus has only one move that defends
the position and it is the one that we
mentioned and probably why king to f1 is
the only attempt at a win
because here after bishop captures on g5
you can go for rook captures on h7 with
mate
to follow but black is in time with this
check
it doesn't matter if you move the king
or you capture
because uh well now you now you don't
have the dark square bishop
uh you can simply capture the knight if
the king just moves for example king d1
you're gonna play g characters here
and you don't uh you don't have mate for
example you're gonna go here here and
now you don't have this
uh for it to be made because the bishop
covers it it's just crazy so
sorry so you can go queen to h7 check
but then the king escapes so
in insane stuff so what you would have
to do here after king to g7
is uh there's nothing you cannot you
simply cannot
go for this uh so you would have to
capture the bishop with king captures
here but now comes uh
queen to g5 check and now uh the the
point is clear king c3 now we're going
to go 94 check
king is going to go all the way back and
now g captures and now again
the queen covers the h6 square so there
is no mate and the king happily escapes
here with king to f6
uh or rather not not just yet but after
this quinto h7 check
uh yeah here here
king to f6 does not really escape uh
since rook captures nf8 is the idea
uh and then it's uh well it is just a
pretty crazy position
uh but uh yeah i think here after bishop
captures on d2 king captures
now you go for queen to g5 check and
then king to see three
knights the e4 check and now uh king to
b4
followed by queen to d to check you
don't capture the knight
just yet yeah queen to d to check is the
idea and only then
you continue king to a3 and then you can
go for queen check
bishop blocks and then queen here with
check and the point is after the key
moves and now you go
for this check uh and uh the king now
has to go up the board to help out with
the with the defense of the bishop if
you go here then you run into
complications after knight to d2 check
and so on
so here you would have to settle for a
perpetual here with this move that's
that's the line
so incredibly crazy stuff after this
queen to h3 move that nipple played and
the bishop captures on g5 is the only
saving move for black however magnus
missed it he played h5
and now it is only move 19 but magnus is
now completely lost and
plus uh he's down to some or less than a
minute on the clock napo is like
up on the clock 10 minutes so nipple
really prepared this line and
it seems that it wasn't enough to to
cover all the lines just with
some preparation in between games but
yeah feel free to pause the video while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it i'm sure all of you got it
so congratulations to everyone it is
rook to g5
uh root captures on h5 so we're all just
going to enjoy the show
uh now the mate is being threatened
there's not much you can do here magnus
capture but after queen captures on h5
uh i don't think magnus resigned the
game in this position i think he played
one more move like there's knight to e6
here but uh he immediately resigned
after playing that
this move i think maybe it was just uh
something maybe he picked up the knight
he didn't know what to play anymore and
then he just put it on e6 as the 96
doesn't really make any sense
uh but uh yeah it's just it's just gonna
be checkmate uh
so here whatever you play it's checkmate
but okay the move magnus played knight
the e6
will just run into this very nasty g6
move and
that's just it uh here mate is being
threatened and now if you go for this
then it's just made captures captures
with check king to h8
and now queen to h6 we're you're gonna
go here first you're gonna grab this guy
with
check rook to f7 knight h6 check and
everything just falls apart king g7
you're gonna capture here
uh and the knight of course is defended
by the bishop so it's not a problem king
h8
and now just bishop d3 threatening
checkmate and that's
that's all there is uh you you could
block it first but then you open up this
diagonal for the
for the dark square bishop and then that
then that's just it you can do this but
then just bishop captures queen captures
and now the g8 square is not defended so
this will not work
so what you could do after this knight
the e6 you could uh
like go g6 and then knight to g5 to
block this but it doesn't i mean it
doesn't help just bishop capture still
the same idea is being threatened
and and that's just it if queen here
you're gonna go king f1
if queen to a1 check you're gonna go
king to e2 and
now there are no more checks you are
getting mated
so really really an insane game uh
with so many complications and so many
possible lines and you can see
just how well nepal prepared it but
magnus was able to defend
all the way up to this point but you can
see that it took him so much
time at this point uh uh before he
played h5 he was like a minute on the
clock and then
almost 10 minutes so it was not possible
to defend against all those
pre pre pre pre-prepared moves
so napo and nipple equalizes the match
in game three and now we go into game
four where we will either have a winner
of the first match or we go into blitz
uh tie breaks and then into armageddon
so yeah once again i do hope you enjoyed
it i would once again like to thank john
hart
uh
don dugan and jeff grace for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the
finals of the legends of chess
tournament checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day